[Applaudissements]
on le dit on le répète on a encore la
semaine dernière oui alors est-ce que ça
vous choque non Johnny Depp mais ça
insupportable excusez-moi excusez-moi
la justice a été faite le lieu de toute
façon le Palais des Festivals c'est
certainement pas lieu c'est pas un
tribunal et voilà heureusement que pour
lui sa Carrère elle reprend là il a
sorti
avec Maïwenn qui est la seule à ne pas
l'avoir lâché d'ailleurs pendant pendant
les affaires il a signé un contrat quand
même à 20 millions avec une grosse parc
de parfum et tant mieux pour lui il
voulait vous vouliez quoi qu'il se fasse
huer enfin c'est bon il a droit de
reprendre sa carrière ça veut dire quoi
que ces mec-là qui ont été une fois dans
la sauce après ils ont plus le droit de
travailler
il y a eu 15 millions de dommages j'ai
intérêts on a reconnu qu'il y avait eu
une diffamation vers lui bah lui il a
deux pays
c'est des coupables et là on applaudit
c'est gênant tu as fait du mal et on
t'applaudit ces gens là il a rien eu il
a bien sûr
Jacquouille croquant
de Johnny Hallyday tu dis oui parce que
tu sais pas mais non parce que je suis
désolé consommateur de drogue de toi
ça m'a fait rire de voir ces gens se
lever qui vont donner des leçons qui
vont signer des pétitions pour des pour
me tout et compagnie je suis désolé il a
gagné
on sait très bien qu'il a tapé
violence conjugale il a pas été condamné
mais il a été blanchi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle vivait avec un drogué un alcoolique
qui pouvait avoir un mélange
tout le monde dit vous êtes sûr qu'il
l'a pas touché deux enfants avec lui est
venu avec lui même sa femme elle a
témoigné pour lui que je te raconte
sa femme Vanessa Paradis qui a témoigné
pour lui
dire
je peux comprendre ce que tu dis mais
c'est complètement à côté de la plaque
parce que en fin de compte non mais à
chaque fois on peut quand même
considérer qu'il y a des hommes qui
tombent sur des grandes tarés aussi
la vérité
excusez-moi on est les premiers à tomber
sur certains
produits
n'écoute plus jamais Johnny Hallyday par
exemple la consommation
du Festival de Cannes avec quelqu'un
comme ça
on se lever il y a il y a quand même 110
actrices qui ont fait une mais qu'est-ce
que tu racontes je ne suis pas la seule
hier 110 actrice qui ont signé quelque
chose pour dire que ça n'a rien à voir
il a été il a gagné
je suis désolé je pense qu'il a une
quarantaine
dernièrement avec beaucoup de morale à
la place de la justice c'est pas oui
c'est quelqu'un de blague quelqu'un
qui a des quartiers tu vas aller prendre
une soupe ma chérie et tu vas te calmer
merci
[Musique]
[Rires]